now this leads me to an important
question if you've got some event and
then the opposite of that event because
these things are meant to cover every
single possibility right this should be
all the things when I add those two
probabilities what should they add up to
hold that thought hold that thought okay
let's have a look
probability of tails on a fair coin is
1/2 right
probability of heads on the same coin
it's 1/2 so 1/2 plus 1/2 equals why I'm
very good let's go to this one here
clubs clubs there's one suit out of how
many in total 4 so the probability of
getting clubs if I pull out a card is
1/4 1/4 probability of the complement of
that is going to be not one quarter but
three quarters what's 1/4 plus 3/4 one
so what do I get every time if I add
these probabilities yes I am NOT
including two joker just that I always
get Joker's out of there because they're
just confusing right so yes when we just
consider all their normal cards our
normal coin 1/2 plus 1/2 1/4 plus 3/4
we're always getting one right and I
don't know what the probability of it
being sunny today is maybe it was like
something with 80% but if I told you
that it was 80%
what could you infer that the
probability of it not being something
would be yeah 20% because they should
add to 1 are you with me okay can I
actually please to open up to 902 902 in
your textbook please already there some
people are very prepared which is
fantastic
[Music]
and what it likes us to do is just look
straight at question - this is 90 -
question - can I get a show of hands
who's already got it open hands up
straight at least one hand should be up
which is yang's anyone else
Krishan you got it yeah who else you got
90 to open you have 90 to open yep
fantastic hands down okay it's coming up
take you here that's right okay now
here's what I'd like to do because I am
had this deck of cards with me write
what I think would be really fun to do
is I have a bunch of mathematical card
tricks that I like to I like to do so
I'd love to show you one which means
that like my time is 954 Bell goes at 10
27 27 so I reckon if we can do a quick
example
you guys can march through the exercise
that I'm about to assign questions for
and then I think I'll take me about five
minutes to show you a card trick does
that sound like a good deal all right
let's go for it so we're on question two
right now and I just want us to have a
look at this situation and make sure
that we understand it and we're writing
it in the correct notation a dyers roll
what's the probability that the result
is and then they give you a bunch of
options okay
so for starters I'm gonna begin with on
this idea here sample space right this
is a relatively simple you know
situation where there's not many
different things that can happen you can
list them all out on a standard die
what's the sample space okay now I heard
the number six I think what you're
telling me is how many things there are
possible right but that doesn't actually
tell me what those events are Krishna
what we'd like to add to that one two
three four five and six of course that
means this
the sample space is 6 but these are the
actual things that can happen and I need
them to answer the questions let's have
a look at Part A it says what's the
probability that result is a three so
I'm just going to write it like so P for
probability and then the event that I'm
interested in is uh 3 how many ways can
that happen on my die just just one of
them right
just that one hey David grab a seat if
it's only once I can then say and this
is where you guys told me before the
size of the sample space there's my
favorite over there and down the bottom
I'll have a six so this is not
complicated it says what's the
probability of not a three so I'm going
to use my copy mode notation here I
could write not three or I can write
three with a bar over the top right so
this is everything except for that right
now what do you think could you do the
equal sign with a line through it you
mean an equal sign with a line through
it like that so what does this mean this
means is not equal to right so I would
say like two is not equal to nine right
whereas this is it does have a slightly
different meaning it means well we're
going to work out using this right I can
work out oh sorry bribed um question uh
yeah it's this idea it's just an extra
piece of notation
it literally means not whatever there's
written there so in fact I could write
it like this I could write the same
thing as not three or the compliment of
three these are all ways of saying the
same thing okay
I'm interested in all of the other
things now what are all the other things
if it's not three then it can be one two
four five or six
so how many of those were okay five of
them and then what's the size of my
sample space again sit so what we did
was we counted up how many different
things could happen and we wrote you
know possible favorable and then we said
okay we'll divide that by the sample
space now there's a simpler faster way
of doing this
that doesn't require us to count
everything up I want you to come back up
here with me look up here what I'm
saying is the probability of one event
and the probability of its complement
what should they add to I should add it
to one right so another way that I could
write this is if they add up to one it
can be one take away the probability of
the regular event the original event
like so do you see that do you see how
this is connected to here just jot that
down right so I could have done this
both ways I could count all of these
guys whoops not that one
sorry you guys counted that there were
five of them so it's five out of six
that are okay or you could just say you
know what I'm just trying to avoid this
event this is the thing I'm trying to
not have so I just say one there's one
takeaway this one out of six does that
make sense and this is often a faster
way to do it